hello and welcome to GameSpot's play for
all we have a special segment here today
because we are talking about the
champion of battle Royales that is apex
legends and I am joined by game director
Chad Grenier how you doing man
yeah area I'm hanging in there but I'm
feeling pretty good because we are
recording this we're having this
conversation ahead of EA play but we got
a little bit of a taste of what y'all
going to be showing at EA play and boy
it is a lot of stuff man kinda want to
throw it to you though to kind of for
those who may not have caught it give a
quick rundown of all the new stuff that
apex is showing off there's a lot it's a
really exciting time for announcements
so first off starting on June 23rd
Tuesday lost treasures collection event
was coming to Apex
so all new skins tons of new content
that you can you know purchase or unlock
for free by doing challenges and things
like that so there's a lot of really
great stuff there it also comes with the
new limited time mode so about maybe six
months ago or so we did a mid time movie
called armed and dangerous which was
snipers and shotguns only so we're
bringing that back it was a fan favorite
but we put a slight twist on it
so all the respawn beacons that are
throughout the map that you used to to
respawn your buddies when they're down
we've deleted them all out of the map
however we've got a brand new item so we
adding the mobile respawn beacon which
is an item that you have in your
inventory at the start of the match and
you can also loot them from death boxes
and whatnot so it's an item you carry in
your inventory and it lets you call in a
respawn vegan anywhere you want a lot
like lifelines care package right and
kind of you point it and you call it any
come from the sky so now you'll be able
to respawn your buddies any more than
that which is a huge game changer it's
really cool so that's like on the
gameplay side continents in game mode we
also just announced some big bombs which
are bringing the game to steam so we
heard all the fans like cool origin what
about Steve and now you can play on
either one and
also crossplane so you'll be able to
play with your origin and your scheme
and your Xbox and Playstation friends
you know you can invite each other and
play with cross play and also platform
expansion we just announced which oh
that's wild man also compatible with
cross bike wow that's that's wow that's
that's probably the first thing I want
to get into I mean maybe not not too
much detail or as much detail as you can
about how challenging is it to bring a
game as big and as detailed as apex
legends to a much different platform
yeah it's a big challenge we've been
working on for a while and yeah there's
it's not with those challenges but you
know I'll say it's looking really good
and it's running really well obviously
it's a you know it's a different
platform and we have to make some
changes for the game to run there and
you know it's got the it's got the
motion controller and so we're
supporting that so that takes some time
to support via you know the gyro aim
functionality and so yeah I mean it's a
lot of work but it's coming along nicely
and we're you know we're testing it at
this point making sure that it's good to
go and so yeah it you know it's worth it
we're huge fans in Nintendo so I'm
personally really excited to just you
know bring the game to switch and I can
take it on the go and play one on you
know with my kids or whatever well one
more thing about switch since it's gonna
be cross play every day it's going to be
obviously caught up with all of the
content once it releases correct yeah
yeah we plan on having all four
platforms well five if you count as
scheme with each other same season the
same content cross play all that good
stuff so yeah because it'll be the same
game well I know that there's been a lot
of questions about cross play and
obviously the more and more it's
implemented the happier the fan bases
will be because it's it's a it's an
exciting thing to be able to play with
so many more players so many more
possibilities and we've seen it in games
such as call of duty modern warfare on
your end what does it take to bring a
game to
cross-play across different platforms
yeah it's all it's mostly just technical
challenges so you know the systems are
pretty segregated from a tech
perspective they run on the same servers
I want to get too technical here but a
lot of the challenges come from making
sure that that we can intermix the
various systems we've got like all your
player data data that's stored so if
you're a place they can fire and you
know there's a file that contains all of
your your progression what you own and
your player level and all that kind of
stuff right what's in you haven't and
now we're crossing streams with like
Xbox and PC and we need to make sure
that all that data is preserved and not
getting mixed up and whatnot so there's
just a ton of back-end server type work
that has to go into it as well as some
front-end stuff like how do you invite
friends so if I'm playing on xbox and
you're on PlayStation well you know
those friends invite systems don't work
with each other so now we have to add a
way for us to invite each other which is
you know which is a new system I can't
send you an Xbox party invite up here
not an Xbox or so there's some back-end
stuff there's some front-end UI work
there's a lot of work but in the end I
think it's worth it right like we're
gonna be on all these different
platforms and would love to play with my
friends I play on xbox most of my
friends play on PC or Playstation err
you know so I can't wait to play them
cool yeah and coming to steam is pretty
huge for the PC player base can you give
any insight as to the decision is it was
it just player feedback or did you have
any conversations valve or how to like
end with between you and EA like how
does that how does that shake out
obviously EA has origin which is their
platform for getting games on PC but EA
has a larger initiative to try to get a
lot of their games on Steam it's not
just Apex
however the apex team has always wanted
to be on steam for a long time we're all
avid PC gamers you know I have organized
even Stahl I've got friends on on scheme
that I would love to play with so it
felt natural for us to go to see him I
think when you're trying to launch a
game you know you kind of have to pick
and choose what your priorities are and
you know we we prioritize you know
putting our efforts into
the game great and now that we're kind
of logged was really great cadence of
seasons and we sort of hit our stride
now we're looking at cool now we can go
to scheme and you know worked out well
with me a larger initiative to bring
your names to scheme I think that open
doorways for us now I want to shift over
to some of the more gritty details on
the gameplay side because you do have
you're all well you're bringing back an
old mode in a different fashion now it
seems that it revolves around crypto can
you tell me a little bit more about the
sort of the thematic things around
bringing back armed dangerous yeah so
crypto gets his town take over now so we
we've slowly rolled out these these
legend town takeovers in the map we you
know got the okapi Gotland the rate the
rate voidwalker bunker and of course
what hounds town take over with they had
the prowlers in it so those now getting
a part of the map if they called the map
room and it's got a big giant satellite
dish on top of this building and it
looks very crypto II it's green and
white and it you know it looks like
you're from color scheme and there
there's some cool gameplay changes in
there if you go into that bunker there's
a it's called the map room because
there's a hologram version of the entire
team Canyon map so you go in there and
there's a button you can activate and it
sends out a blast from the satellite
dish and it actually seems the location
of all the enemies in the map on that
hologram version of the map that you can
that you can see in front of you
so in a sense you can go there ping the
whole map and see where everyone is on
that hologram version now that doesn't
mean you can like literally just go find
the exact point on the map and go kill
them because well it takes time to get
there and know how to whatnot but it's a
really cool thing you can do it also
tells you how many squads are in the
immediate area so that you know maybe
you decide you don't want to push the
button if there's a couple squads nearby
they're gonna see you activate the dish
maybe seek you out knowing that you're
enough so it's a cool gameplay change
there's a lot of fun I like to go in
there and hit it and then
try to people that it beings on that
usually died trying to that book yeah
that that's uh you guys always
incorporate like small little changes
that kind of actually have big
implications for the moment-to-moment
gameplay I remember when the vaults
first came out you know everyone was was
going to find vault keys and like trying
to figure out how to get vault keys and
then all the big fights would happen
around these vaults and I'm just like
scrambling to get my legendary armor so
I don't I don't go down or I can auto
revive and all that good stuff so yeah
what's it like to kind of incorporate
and balance some of those those wild new
gameplay additions
yeah well say those those additions are
just they just come from like innovative
designers and people just find things so
you know we do play test every day at
respawn we play apex varying versions of
apex every day sometimes we're playing
like the very next release like maybe
we're playing 5.1 before it comes out we
also play tests things like some of the
content we're gonna see in like Season
ten right super more out it's like a
year away we play does that too and
there's just all these crazy things in
the works that we try we throw away 90%
what we do as far as the prototype so
you know like the mobile respawn beacon
it was it was some ideas someone came up
with at one point and sorry I don't you
know there's like hey what if you could
just carry these things and just deploy
them anywhere right it's like okay let's
try it and put it with the other five
things we're gonna try and split them
and then some things you know stick and
some things you know undergo a couple
revisions and we sometimes can it but
you know that's the fun about working on
this game is it's a live service game
the game is never finished so when
there's ideas we just try them and
eventually if they're good they make
their way into an update like like the
mobile respawn vegan or Kryptos map room
and we've got we've got like 10 more of
those really cool things that I would
love to talk about obviously Canada yeah
you know and of those 10 things I'm
excited about probably only five of them
will ever make it into the game and the
other five will be like that with a good
idea but you know it's back to the game
or it's not healthy or maybe there's a
better version there speed of those
ideas that you
implement along the way I think quests
have been a kind of a big hit across the
board because of its ability to flesh
out the characters a bit more because
that's like one of our favorite things
about apex legends is getting to know
the roster not just playing as them but
quests have been great what's the
feedback been like and how do you plan
on evolving quests if at all yeah quest
was really just an experiment to see how
we could tell more story and apex we
have a team of people who love to tell
story and before apex know we made a
campaign titanfall to hold a ton of
story there yeah and so then moving on
to making a multiplayer only apex game
worked and left wondering how can we
tell story in the VR game is that even
possible and we found ways to do that
through transmedia storytelling and our
character teases and the dialogue and
the quest is just an evolution of trying
to tell story in the multiplayer game
and so you know we've been listening to
all a lot of the feedback and I think I
think in general people are enjoying
playing the quest you know if anything
the feedbacks just been that people want
more of that lore and storytelling so
we're you know we're finding new ways to
bring that content in future seasons you
know just listening and learning and
we're trying to involve the way that
we're doing it and find it works best I
think you know season six maybe a little
bit different than five and that's just
us iterating and trying to try new
things and see what works see what
doesn't work and listen to the fans
and speaking of listening to the fans I
know there's been I guess you could say
conversations around skill based
matchmaking kind of where where do you
stand where are you and the team
currently stand on that and yeah well
what's what are some of the ideas you
have around maybe changing skill based
matchmaking or like um iterating on it
yeah it's a hot topic both with the fans
and in respawn as well right so we
understand all the feedback that we get
from you know
look online and hear about it every day
and we get it but there's multiple sides
to the story and so we're trying to
evaluate all the data and trying to do
what's best for the game as a whole so
it's really tough because you've got say
some beginner players or more mediocre
players you know kind of me all the road
and you want them to have a good
experience and so you want them to get
in the game get engaged get some kills
get some wins occasionally because if
someone comes in and they try out apex
and they get stomped they're not gonna
keep playing so that's obviously not
good for the game it's not good for the
players who love the game because right
we want the game to grow and we want we
want the player count to increase and
you know so we keep supporting the game
on the other hand you know I get we have
some highly skilled players and it's all
over the place I hear I hear some highly
skilled players right they just want to
go pubstomp and they want to just kill
all these newbies right newbies don't
like that so we try to create a skill
based matchmaking which has always been
in the game by the way spawned right you
know so we say okay well these highly
skilled players they should play against
other highly skilled players and be
competitive this is a competitive
shooter we don't want them just stomping
all these beginners and the makeup of
that experience right that's the two
sides of the point so we're always
trying to find that balance right we've
got tons of data that we look at we look
at how long are people playing the game
like how many Holly's Season 5 is the
highest ever the amount of time people
are playing per week on average is
higher than ever bit retention is higher
than it's ever been even since launching
so we're looking at some like really
good data that's showing that our game
is trending in the right direction for
pipeline engagement we just brought in
horny players and any other season have
so that tells me that we have a healthy
game high level I understand there are
still going to be some players who
disagree about certain aspects of skill
base mapping but we just look at it
holistically everything is trending
really well to a healthy apex team that
gets many years of support mm-hmm so how
do we maintain that while still making
all those competitive players happy
right so that's the discussions we have
at least one because we want to make
sure that those new players
and the players who struggle to get wins
are still having a great experience as
well and that's and that's why it's so
tricky so we'll continue to tweak
iterate listen we're always we're always
tweaking things in the back in the
matchmaking system so if people notice
things that are you know things getting
worse or better speak up cuz we're
listening and we'd love to make it right
for everybody if that's even possible
alright last question I'm not sure if
you're gonna be able to answer this but
I am obligated to ask about how apex
plans on transitioning into the next
generation because we've seen destiny to
kind of laid out its plans and fortnight
is laid out its plans so these other
live service based games have kind of
already let us know how they're going to
make that transition is there anything
you can say about apex legends doing
that there's nothing we can announce at
this time but I will say that we are
excited about the new platforms and I'm
you know Sony just you know revealed the
details about their new Playstation
five-sided would love to be on those
platforms but yeah we hit run have
anything to announce at this time okay
cool fair enough and is there anything
else before I let you go that you want
to add that maybe we should have touched
on earlier play the game it's uh it's
it's in a great place like I said we've
got more players playing you know every
every week than we've ever had and we've
got a great event starting on the 23rd
the mobile respawn beacon is the game
changer we've also got a ton of meta
changes and character balance tweaks and
nurse and buffs coming
so check out 5.1 on the 23rd thanks for
playing and supporting the game we're
super excited to you know see the
success the game and we appreciate all
the fans out there
cool props to you and the team at
respawn because like I said earlier apex
Legends is the champion of battle
Royales right now so if you haven't
played definitely check it out and
there's so much more stuff coming there
so thank you for taking the time out of
your day to talk with us ahead of EA
play Chad and yeah best of luck to you
and the team moving forward and for all
you fine folks out there thank you for
watching us we have so much more content
for play for all
so I hope that you stick with us here at
GameSpot and we'll see you there
[Music]